what about success tell me about a
success tell me about a successful
dating moment you know I I met someone
actually just under a year ago we're
still together so well we actually ended
up meeting online but that's neither
here nor there
but he plays in a band his band is Joe
in the jungle he is the Joe of Joe in
the jungle does clever name and so so he
wanted me to come to see him do a show
and at this point we've been dating for
about a month so I was like okay I'm
like listening to the CD I want to learn
the lyrics to the songs I'm a really
good girlfriend
and so I show up and I'm like oh this is
you know it's at this cool dive bar in
Pasadena and I'm like cool like it's
just gonna be like this guy that I've
know well he's playing his music no big
deal well he gets on the stage and like
the first guitar riff and I'm just like
just like moosh yeah I'll explain to you
in the commercial break
it was like it was like I was 13 years
old it was like I was like I was
watching like my favorite band of all
time and I'd start like like this like
screaming how to hit a dive bar in
Pasadena and so he finished the show he
comes off he's like this big guy all
this long areas all sweat he's got a
guitar in one hand and he like grabs me
and lifts me up with one other arm
kisses me on the mouth and I was like
well I guess we have to have sex now you
go to the bathroom all of the doors on
the stalls are only like chest level and
I've run into this a lot yeah perils
being tall so anyway a girl comes in and
then rats on us to security because she
saw him so you're in the stall with this
singer your beau correct yeah and yes
we're railing and a guy you guys ratted
on so what a security guard comes in
here two guards like you guys go to stop
doing that and then it was I remember it
was International Women's Day and I got
like legitimately offended it was like
as a woman I should be able to have sex
with whoever I want wherever I want
whenever I want
screw rules and laws
[Applause]
I'm going to the bathroom right here you
can't just go to the back so square so
this is the guy I met yeah okay kicks us
out I'm yelling something about being a
feminist anyway and we decided let's
just go to a diner so him in one of his
band mates and I go to this diner we're
eating Reubens or something it was
delicious and we go to the bathroom I go
to the bathroom and it's a giant room
with nothing but one toilet in the
corner and so I was like hey jackpot I
stick my head out and I was like hey
buddy we got something to finish yeah
yeah yeah you know he took me from
behind over a dirty toilet in a Denny's
and it's been love ever since
[Applause]
this you know what that questionnaire
that they said they couldn't help you
maybe this was what the breakthrough
yeah yeah okay well that's also a good
ad for Denny's yeah yeah moons over my
hammy you know my
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]